let's try converting equations in the
exponential form to equations in the
logarithmic form and vice versa
what is 7 to the power 3 equal to its
343 and what about 2 to the power 6 it
will equal 64 these two equations are in
the exponential form now I want you to
try writing them in the logarithmic form
I'm sure that was easy
remember the answer of the logarithm is
the power so we can write this one as
log of 343 to the base 7 equals 3 if you
just look at the left hand side it asks
7 raised to what will give us 343 and
the answer is 3 and similarly this can
be written as log of 64 to the base 2 is
equal to 6 so converting from
exponential form to the logarithmic form
was easy how about I give you a couple
of equations in the logarithmic form say
this example and this one try writing
these two equations in the exponential
form
ok so 6 raised to what will give us 216
that's right
6 raised to 3 will give us 216 and this
one's interesting as we have a negative
answer 2 raised to negative 1 will equal
0.5 or 1/2 so by now you should be
pretty confident about both forms
exponential as well as logarithmic